commitment level in your movies are so
crazy I cannot [ __ ] watch it yeah I
commit like I literally look at it and I
and my I don't know why it stops no I
don't die no but if there's a part of me
because I love you you know I really do
I love you as a person and you're my
friend and I be just when your face gets
stretched out and it's all yeah it's all
wet you know I mean I liquefied you know
people who've known me like outside of
porn before porn do not like to watch my
porn I mean I guess that's normal but
yeah I think it freaks them out too late
well yeah I mean I masturbated to you
before see here's what happened wait
what's going the way no streaking out
the white guys look at the white guys
are like I crossed the line a white line
never ever masturbated to AUSA I think
there was something wrong with you when
she because I think I've masturbated to
awesome want you to yeah when she before
okay after the Facebook dominatrix thing
I lost touch with what you did right and
so I would I have this porn right where
it's like a black black with Asians I
know something kind of something like
that right that's probably a real porn
title yeah and I used to like that kind
because you know the little Asian girls
their pajamas get stretchy down like the
guy from the Fantastic Four
I remember watching we had only been
together I think two three months and I
told him it's like hey let me blow you
to some porn but he chose the oddest old
tape that I had ever seen in my life it
was like yeah it was like an a like I
don't even
it was like an old CD I think it was
five Asian guys and they were all not
well-endowed but it was done in Asia and
was it job
yeah he especially got super excited
when the guy with the smallest dick was
the one getting blown which one it is
right there wasn't no that's how what
you you you have the situation wrong I
know what point you're talking about
this it's a bunch of white dudes in
Florida you know that showed the affair
yes just were alright and this is what
happened this is why I love it okay
there's one girl and she's blowing all
five guys and there's one black guy
there's one asian guy oh that's right
yeah there's one Asian guy and he's left
out of the circle all right he's like
cuckolded yeah he can't get into the
[ __ ] circle oh wait is that this is
that supposed to happen no no it wasn't
no those are the theme he was just he
was confused and he was scared and he
was Asian and it wasn't well you know
everyone so let me back up Danny Danny
yeah that was that right you know you
know what the black guy not necessarily
Asian but like you know it always a guy
and the black guy goes yo you miss
someone right
and they keep he separates a little
space and this little Asian guy pops
through with his little little purple
penis right her and she kind of looks at
it like it is that gum right and then
she says blowing yeah and for some
reason and he in his face the expression
like it's almost as if he won the
lottery I don't know it was the struggle
because he was finally accepted yeah it
was also a Lord of the Rings kind of a
thing working he had the ring he went
through all the mines of moria you know
me yeah he went through all the dead sea
or the swamp yeah and he finally got to
the thing you know I mean that's what I
felt like a voyage and when he gets
there you know man I go yeah yeah
because I like to know what he's coming
to or what dream huh but then when I
look back it's just like the you know
sweaty asian guy just finally getting
yeah a few seconds in the episode after
I saw your I masturbated to one scene
this black with the Asian chain and then
and then when I saw you at DVD si and I
go oh and then I thought oh no what have
I done and I the second now I [ __ ] a
sister or something like that's what do
a sister oh so then I went back into my
pornography collection I still there
archive but I because you're always in
the cover of them if there's any agent
anything you're the front cover you're
on the DVD disc yeah you're the star on
every side on
[Music]